[Music]
you
[Music]
and welcome this is just an incredibly
exciting event everybody at Google cloud
is so proud of the customers that we
have here today our customers and
partners will see many ways to leverage
all of Google speed Google Maps Android
YouTube our devices ecosystems Google
let me talk to give it hi I need a
anything ask me what something is worth
we put a security tip to serve as the
basis of trust for that machines
identity in fact is so small that I'm
actually wearing one on my earring here
[Applause]
[Music]
Ripper's why the next step for AI must
be democratization we at Google clouds
are making the tools available but it's
up to you to put them to use Chambord is
the white board in the cloud in the
meeting room and beyond your meeting
room
you start thinking communicating and
working with your team the core promise
to developers still remains the same
bring your code and Google will handle
everything else what really inspires us
and motivates us it's thinking about
what all of us can build together just
gets the cloud now there's no time to
waste in one
[Music]
name